So what should prevention really look like?
Well, prevention has to be geared on diet, and it has to be geared on lifestyle.
So it's, I mean, that's really the bottom line is what we're choosing, how we're choosing
to live.
The issue, the problem is that we live in a world that's corrupt and it's poisoned, you know,
this was not dyed with blueberries, and so I'm exposed to chemicals just sitting here.
We can't get away from that, but we can make wise choices.
Unfortunately, we live in a society that Bon Santo is the good guy and we're addicted
to fast foods.
So it has to come from a consumer-driven approach.
I mean, the whole, look at the organic market today, 10 years ago, it didn't really exist,
you know, and now it is completely commodity-driven.
So that's what we need to do at a grassroots basis of getting people to make proper choices
so that that will drive the market.